Speaker 1: Another thing that is haunting
the Democrats ahead of the 2022 midterms,
Joe Biden's approval rating has taken another
major hit, this time among young voters,
those aged 18 to 30, according to the
latest round of polling out there.
Joe Biden now has a net negative 23 percent
approval rating with that particular age group
that, for the record, helped push him past Donald
Trump in the 2020 election. His disapproval
rating with that age group right now is 50
percent approval rating. With that age group
is 27 percent. That's where you get the twenty
three net difference between the two numbers.
And that, again, is going to hurt Joe
Biden in the midterms and of course,
the Democratic Party, since Joe Biden is clearly
not on the ballot there. But that age group
which does now, you know, when you take the
millennials and the other age groups, they make
up one of the largest voting blocs in the country.
They are the largest voting bloc in the country.
So when they're looking at this administration
after putting you in office just a year ago
and they're saying we're not happy with what
you're giving us because what you're giving us is
effectively nothing, then that's a big problem for
the Democratic Party that they're going to have to
find a way to overcome prior to those midterms.
One of the things obviously driving factor in
this decision to no longer support Joe Biden
with his age group is the student loan debt
Biden specifically promised. And you can still go
back on his Twitter feed and see where he promised
$10000 student loan debt forgiveness, at
the very least $10000. And it's not there.
Oh, sure, he is forgiven debt for some people.
But you've got to jump through so many hoops in
order to qualify for the debt that has been
forgiven so far that it effectively amounts
to what one percent maybe of total debt held.
I think it's actually lower than one percent.
No, that's not good enough, you're not
going to win back over this age group
that is saddled with one and a half
trillion dollars of student loan debt.
With a one percent forgiveness for some people who
meet all of these, you know, very strict criteria
not happening. And for the record, student
loan debt does not just affect that generation.
You have people in their 60s in this
country that still have student loan debt.
You know, obviously a lot of that is because
these people went to college late in their lives.
But they're still paying this off. This is an
issue that does affect every generation here
in the United States. It is not just
the young voters, but specifically he
promised them. He told them again, it's still
on Twitter. You can go and see it for yourself.
And he hasn't done it. And that's something
that he could do via executive order
now, for the record, too. There's a lot of
people out there who say, no, he can't do
it via executive order. A lot of people who
says, yes, he can do it via executive order.
And the discrepancy between the two is has to
do with the public student loan debt and the
private student loan debt. Meaning if you took out
your federal loans, you know you did your FAFSA
and you got your student loans from the federal
government itself, you know, the Department of
Education. That's what Biden could forgive
now if you took out separate student loans
because banks do offer those that would probably
take an act of legislation. Right. I know I had a
couple myself. The interest rates on those were
absolutely astronomical, but luckily for me,
the amounts I took out from private banks
were so small I was able to pay them off,
you know, within a 10 year period. Not, not
quickly, obviously, but those I did work to pay
off first because I really couldn't get deferment
on those either. And that actually, unfortunately,
is a lot of the problem. Those private student
loan debts, the ones with the higher interest
rates, the ones with the stricter criteria in
order to get deferments and forbearance. So that
does take an act of legislation. But Biden could
for this age group at the very least, give this
executive order. Show them he's doing something,
show them. He understands their concerns
for the future. Throw them a bone here. And it
may just help to save Democrats in the midterms,